[Música]
ea pergunta é é feita por muitas vezes
temos redes sociais os tempos
zezinho lado temos os bombeiros temos o
palermo para quem precisa de nós já
sabemos tudo lembra o que aconteceu aqui
ao lado é é um dia três trazem impedimos
no final sem ter as pessoas muitas
centenas de pessoas simplesmente não
eram centenas de pessoas mas lemos
nestes mais que eu sofri nomeadamente
nas redes sociais que via é é uma
dimensão muito maior de uma tragédia em
si só gera uma imensa tragédia
foram precisos noite a contar a verdade
mesmo assim se calhar nas nossas - eles
não existem dúvidas de que a história
não foi bem em contato porque as pessoas
foram os vendo outras histórias
nomeadamento nessas áreas paralelas onde
pensar que tudo kléber revelado é e não
escolhemos um sítio certo para perceber
não trabalho com efeito na lista qual é
gravado no final quando as pessoas que
morreram naquela estrada é eo que tenha
efetivamente é conhecido ficou na dúvida
estamos num tempo de grandes dúvidas
entre grandes desafios também para nós
lojistas o que os obriga a ter uma maior
atenção em tudo o que fazemos e tudo
aquilo que transmitimos neste dias
tragédia é a preocupação é grande é é a
nossa responsabilidade aumenta porque
vocês querem saber exatamente o que
aconteceu esse ano a noite nos disseram
uma coisa que não é falar vocês no dia a
seguir não estão lá pra ver e ele
rapidamente volta atrás de quem me falou
nada
ou então fica uma dúvida e vou tentar
distorcer sempre no sítio onde vocês
foram encontradas dúvida redes sociais
que é uma praga imensa
nessa altura nos mesmo lemos tentar
outra vez no facebook com seus livros
é eu ia dizer que aquilo é muito pior do
que é vizinho da frente e dizer mal
o o do padrão passará ea dizer que
alguém entrou naquela casa terminada
hora e que aquela mulher afinal nos
encontros e desencontros bonitas olhar é
muito pior do que isso deve ter uns
tranquilidade do mundo quando vamos à
procura de notícias
na foto que encontraram para complicar
ainda mais as coisas não quer no twitter
e no facebook a jornais falte news não
só nos estados unidos não é só o
trânsito é um evento dessa coisa acho
mais que digam todos os dias a notar
figuras públicas é é inventar uma coisa
qualquer que não passou pela cabeça de
um cientista e dizemos que o nosso
salário no final vai ser cortado ainda
mais porque vamos ter um aumento
extraordinário punição importantes no
exterior e portanto os mais tradicionais
em portanto jornal impresso porque o
contrário do que se tem dito ao longo
dos anos e não está condenado nós
acreditamos não está impresso porque que
é imutável está impresso falar em casa
completa está no quiosque se temos
alguma dúvida e voltamos atravessou o
início da notícia e notícia estava
inscrita no online não se instalar
naquela surdo nos fundos que pode ser
alterado é aquela vapor foi transmitida
online é uma provável que não é fruta é
muito mutável e e e não se garante a
confiança que os mal impresso
nem a responsabilidade que o jornal
impresso nos traz o mesmo valor na
televisão vocês conheçam para uma rádio
que vocês conheçam se vocês me ouvirem a
é dar uma turbinada notícia atender
algum grau de credibilidade que não dão
certo também confessou que vocês nunca
viram uma televisão que vocês nem
imaginam é que esfrie mas que estava no
ar e dá tempo de sobra no computador
olha é isso que está a viver esta coisa
e acreditando que o longa data
por isso aqui portanto
é exigência também por isso é importante
a existência de duas listas com os nomes
têm que viver é e os padrões dos
analistas principalmente é gosta o que
os jornais não muito que isto visões
verão muito que ela não seja um imenso
sucesso e temos dois caminhos para fazer
isto
um grande milagre que é o caminho que
nos garantir que amanhã em estímulos ou
que o caminho-de-ferro é todos ter uma
primeira página muito positiva toda a
gente vai comprar é mas aqui não é falar
aconteceu no méxico é de ontem na
história aproveitamente inacreditável de
uma negociação à escala global nos deve
fazer pensar a previsão estava em um
momento complicado com algumas
convivências serviço da proteção civil é
consoante fundir notícias sobre a
existência de uma menina debaixo dos
escombros de uma escola nem falava em
frases completas
a menina brincava conosco e nós vamos
nos domina a menina nunca existiu foi
uma invenção foi uma invenção para fazer
vender naquela televisão com o
universidad alguém certamente não o fez
porque é que o senhor está um caos por
ela fez por um outro de 13 isto mostra
que muitas vezes para atingir esse fim
de uma audiência é um caminho que
escolhe não é o da jornada não é uma
transferência de pessoal temos imensos
exemplos apelo à vossa inteligência é e
na hora de escolher nós devemos olhar
claramente próprio do que estamos a
construir porque ninguém gosta de ser
enganada
a primeira a cair todos depois a partir
daí somos todos inocentes é e e é
importante nós fazemos essa estranheza
porque as mais importantes que falava e
que não vê no entanto como temos que nos
enganam todos os dias nós a qualquer
coisa e não sei se é um gênio
para explicar isso a qualquer coisa do
sul é comprar uma coisa que nós temos
que meter estranho não consigo explicar
mesmo carregar no botão daquilo que na
oposição o nós sabemos que o que estou a
dizer não é lá faço exercício eu quero
ficar aqui ficam os 20 que o que
acontece muitas vezes esses direitos não
só a esquerda o que é ficar atento e não
sabia sequer onde ficava e transmitido
em directo aqui no thanks
olhe pra trás de contenção que não está
na tabela neste momento estou certa que
ela porque ela é que ela estava isso é
só olhar para mim isso ele é e não posso
fazer um directo no momento mas que
quando as pessoas o que está a acontecer
porque eu não sei o que está acontecendo
enquanto não sei fazer directos
felizmente nos entregar antes de ver
esta desta capacidade imensa fantástica
de fazer é toda hora quando chegava a um
sítio qualquer
antes de fazer a minha história tenha
perceber qual é a história não eu posso
contar senão perceber
atualmente nós não percebemos muitas
vezes nós não percebemos esse é um sítio
qualquer e fui de fazer direto já está
saindo direto e estamos em directo a
contar uma coisa que nós não conhecemos
e temos cenas caricatas costas também
contra o sacramento neto jornalista
serem insultados das pessoas que são
altamente time deles não foi assim e tal
vai embora ea criança que fazer e nós
colhemos as vicinais é é alimentamos
essa é essa loucura do directo e
indirecto estão lá e não contar nada
duvido muito quando vem tudo em directo
é de um imenso desconto e por ser um
socorrista sabe o que estava a fazer e
nós consegue contar uma história só
esquerda
é ter pressionado é mais letal coisa
ainda seja ele pessoa
escolhemos escolhemos isso é e e vamos
vamos vamos evoluindo com a idéia de que
estamos juntos estamos informados
é o jornalismo tem existência nessa
altura eu acredito que vá vencer já
aconteceu várias vezes só uma história
dos mundiais podem ser essa
essa linha mais na histeria que não tem
que ser cinzenta não tem que ser e é
muito chata e funcional em pé em 30
minutos acaba em análise já que um dos
temas
as pessoas falam comigo é porque até que
nós confessamos facilmente uma conversa
curta esteve a fazer muito mais profunda
então sentamos e conversamos com que nós
calma e é assim que nós fazemos a nossa
vida uma entrevista não ter melhor pode
ter quatro minutos e dizer tudo em meia
hora pra não dizer rigorosamente nada
uma hora pode não dizer é absolutamente
nada é e transmitir uma notícia nós para
além da história que contamos temos que
encontrar campos que dá pistas para que
vocês que estão do outro lado consigo
perceber efetivamente o que está em
causa não temos que mandar é nem sequer
temos que criar a vossa opinião temos
que despertar a curiosidade pra vocês
terem depois uma opinião e isso acontece
no comentário político
quando falamos de ciência quando falamos
de assuntos internacionais
agora por exemplo desta questão da cota
única é uma coisinha que eu conheço
muito bem é mal isto só nós temos um
grande time
os ladrões e e em várias lojas que está
aí não é condenada a 15 anos vão fazer
frente nenhum senão atenção ao quadro
legal que estão a provar hora é esta
movimentação hoje temos esta esta
situação
uma outra no princípio tem passado ao
lado curiosa
vamos olhar para o estado islâmico que o
combate ao estado islâmico e por ser um
grupo e nós é piada os curdos que estava
a lutar contra o estado islâmico apoiado
e armado pelos estados unidos pela
frança mas deve sempre a linha nacional
de história jesus mandou
e no dia que agora é esta primeira
batalha contra o estado islâmico os
cursos vão dizer uma coisa óbvia
os portugueses já disseram alguns
séculos desculpa lá nós queremos a nossa
padres e empreendendo se não fazê lo
agora contra a vontade dos estados
unidos que osmar dos franceses que os
inspiraram é dos iranianos que
utilizaram dos turcos que tsonga e que
os querem aniquilar dos iraquianos que
utilizaram e nós temos sociedade
fizemos duas outras notícias sobre isto
é os curtos deixaram de ser os amigos
porque estavam lado das forças do bairro
está contra o estado islâmico e passaram
a ser uns desgraçados que estão lá no
curdistão que lógico raio é e lá se
desenrasquem seus tem pátria vontade nós
não queremos saber as notícias são
eternas e nós não conseguimos temos
tanta informação não conseguimos depois
perceber o que está a acontecer neste
nosso mundo é chávez piada é esse grupo
e alimentarmos esse grupo
curiosamente portugal até seu alguns
refugiados que vieram não intencional do
planeta
recolhemos muito bem e estão cá os
curtos easily e mulheres grupos foram
duramente perseguidos e muito bem e
ainda bem que os temos
mas depois não conseguimos sequer de
gerir a informação sobre o que está
acontecendo na altura da terra deus e
muito importante prêmio foi importante
para nós um dia é alguém dizer que
estela queremos ser independente e e
lutar por isso
é é é mas não vamos olhando para essa
com essa informação ficamos perdidos com
coisas transcendentais é da nossa
política nacional
por exemplo quando temos autárquicas
olhamos para os custos ligados à volta
do homem por cento do pib é esse
assunção cristas foi ao bairro em
favelas vida ou suporte com ele foi não
sei onde que eu matasse lista mas o
primeiro ministro diz qualquer coisa
sobre os salários e os direitos dos
campeões da função pública e feriram os
21 debate figurante e o que pensam os
candidatos ficam a 20 nós temos
encontrado na informação
os órgãos de informação do jornal local
estava o elemento olhar para isso olham
quando passou passos coelho quando
passou
o antónio costa e ela é que grande
figura claro que são importantes na sua
dimensão nacional
mas o quarto nesta altura estar mais no
local vamos falar mais das propostas
não falamos as propostas falamos das
pessoas aí não gosta que eu porque tem
melhor para que nos aqui e outro ali na
home a dell para nossa que investe muito
mal e eles têm propostas discutir temos
participar e ruas ministro num debate
sobre educação é com os candidatos à
câmara de gaia e foi curioso é ouvir as
pessoas falarem da dívida da câmera é
das suas perguntas da platéia da dívida
da câmara de um problema com o argumento
é certamente importante é de uma obra
ficou provado no senhor e não foi feita
uma única pergunta sobre as escolas do
estado às escolas sobre os professores
sobre os auxiliares sobre as cantinas
fiquei assustado que o confesso fiquei
só porque as pessoas vão 4 sobre
educação perguntar sobre estradas são
importantes óbvio mas não só na escola
mas tudo isto não sair que nós possamos
aprender não será na escola que nós
fazemos o primeiro jornal é a primeira
parada foi na escola que eu não sei
fazer nada
foi uma desgraça e ainda hoje continuo é
gostar muito de lado e dizer que um dia
queria fazê-la envolvimento é é
importante nós temos esse reconhecimento
e nós não estamos queremos disputar
temos que vos informar e temos que vamos
falar a verdade se vocês quiserem ouvir
falar porque olhando para alguém
assistir televisão e para as tiragens
dos jornais
eu acho que os portugueses não querem
saber falar e de vez em quando ter um
contacto com a realidade mas continuamos
ali num mundo mais ou menos paralelo no
link mais ou menos paralela é de ilusão
e discutir e votar agora aqui é muito
importante
transgenital nesta altura do morro
estudo foi esta semana fazer capa com
madonna
o colégio dos veículos com produção vai
lá é a história da madonna eu acho que e
eu estávamos naquele artigo forma
cruzada por não conseguir ler se ele não
conseguir suster a importância da coisa
mas eu fiquei um homem muito melhor pois
ela tentou assim abandona vai mudar o
nosso nosso país nós tenhamos a dona não
seria efetivamente nada mas alguém vai
comprar raiva daquela vista felizmente
os meus colegas teriam sempre nesta
altura nós queremos sim está sem emprego
em curso de nível que é capa de uma
revista
a duas semanas das eleições autárquicas
seja é uma zona muito importante que as
ligações seja feliz em lisboa no álbum
ela quiser
se eu for para lá nana nenê infelizmente
também não é
mas por que nós temos disse lucílio é
olharmos preparam uma coisa muito boa
pois o reino dos céus onde as pessoas
ergueram certamente os céus ir todos os
dias e prendem efetivamente muito é e
depois as pessoas que participam nessa
coisa
faye são grandes estrelas sombra às
estrelas é alguém que estuda a vida dona
não é é ser a estrela na sua dimensão na
sua famíla o seu trabalho sua empresa é
o seu campo agrícola
soube que eles tenham essas estrelas
coisa nenhuma que nos mostraram que nem
de sua vida são grandes estrelas nós
viramos e até aves a contar histórias
dessas pessoas e há pessoas que compram
revistas para saber as histórias dessas
pessoas é então temos esta temos é esta
queda é que não conseguimos um trabalho
não é único português que é um enrolado
na hora de português nós somos um dos
países da europa que mais telas com sol
e que mais revistas cor de rosa tem
infelizmente nem todas com sucesso
infelizmente porque
não podemos ter as camareiras e com
aquelas coisas todas em 35 mas muito
grande que tem só três é esse é muito
bem pra ver é para irmos em entrando
nessa nessa cultura dessa cultura
paralela sobre o nosso roberto solistas
e enrosca você tem que ser muito mais
exigente e no dia que nós fazemos agora
vocês têm que prestar favores é tempo
todo espectador
anderson tem profundo nos cantador do do
ouvido
os jornais nem problemas do vitória
completa negão é que é honesta quanto
uma história que não é verdade estou
indignado
isto não pode ser porque a nossa
exigência é é aquilo que você é isso que
querem construir se vocês consomem o
direto do donizete quero chegar aos 120
minutos não sabe onde fica o verão já
está em directo e contar tudo sofrer aos
20 acontece ele acreditava
agora vou ter uma falha a itália
pergunta e não sei que nós colhemos
aquilo e não vamos fazer um racha
particular sobre o microfone vai agora
que voltei daqui duas horas fazem o
primeiro direto
o sef pela crise aqui um disco que
precisa do direto e quero direto quero é
triste né
desde televisiva e vocês nunca vão a
shows internacionais de televisão
é ela que vai precisar de qualquer coisa
disse ela em por lá o gajo indireto e
entra num segundo cenário é é normal
porque é uma fortíssima concorrência é
ea concorrência normalmente nivela as
coisas por cima
ou então como é uma concorrência
simplista nós temos é que correr atrás
do pior que uma coisa não sai nos
enfrentar
não é só fazer uma corrida monótona
qualquer um eu for fazer normal e eu
voltar melhor outras pior nunca nem o
nosso é algo mesmo iguaria é coisa pra
baixo não está acontecendo o contrário
partindo atrás do pi até agora o país
não no segundo semestre está também nos
porque e tem que ser você fazer a
pergunta nós fazemos muitas vezes eu
faço muitas vezes é só vocês a fazer
nenhuma outra força
espero q
está me deixando aquela música e algumas
luzes
espero que continue assim grossmann 29
mãe
[Aplausos]